[Musique]
les indicateurs sont au vert pour les
autorités touristiques de la martinique
mans jour car il nous sauve
bonjour maurice via le temps bonjour à
toutes et à tous présidente du comité
martiniquais du tourisme merci d'être
avec nous avec ce sourire aux lèvres
qu'à la martinique a dépassé le million
de visiteurs en 2017 c'est si
exceptionnel que cela car ils nous ont
pas écoutés c'est carrément plus
qu'exceptionnelle puisque ça un chiffre
historique 1 millions 41 peu plus de
quarante et un mille visiteurs ça n'est
jamais arrivé dans l'histoire de la
martinique depuis qu'on comptabilise le
nombre de touristes donc forcément oui
c'est historique on est très contents
mais on peut encore faire mieux le
potentiel touristique de la martinique
est énorme et il faut qu'on continue à
travailler
on y reviendra mais vous êtes président
du cnt c'est un poste politique par
définition est donc soumis à la critique
aux querelles de partis et déjà cette
question
ce bon chiffre que convient d'évoquer
c'est le fruit du travail de l'actuelle
équipe où ce le fruit de l'est du
travail de l'équipe d'avant de décembre
2015 et bien écoutez je suis arrivé il y
a deux ans comité martiniquais du
tourisme donc ça fait quand même 2 ans
que nous travaillons j'ai trouvé une
situation x à un moment t et il a fallu
à bien oui faire beaucoup de travail en
particulier de restructuration de
l'organigramme
nous travaillons autour de trois axes
d'abord il faut analyser et il n'y avait
pas de d'observatoire touristique
aujourd'hui nous en avons un donc nous
sommes très contents et blanc pour
l'équipe précédente sont pas violents
non non on continue on continue ensuite
deuxième axe il faut structurer donc la
structuration de l'offre très importante
et enfin il faut promouvoir la
martinique les blancs encore voilà donc
ce que l'équipe d'avant ne l'avait pas
fait c'est la griffe mousse au sol
ecoutez-la griffon sauce et d'avoir
donné je dirais à chaque
salarié du comité du tourisme une
feuille de route ce qui n'était pas le
cas avant donc c'est vrai que nous avons
beaucoup avancé que nous sommes
aujourd'hui très efficace les raisons de
ce succès une augmentation donc de la
fréquentation touristique de la
martinique avec l'amérique du nord le
canada les etats unis c'est
l'internationalisation de notre
destination qu'on avait souvent évoqué
qui est donc effective là aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez ce qui est très
important pour nous et ça a été une de
mes priorités c'est de diminuer la
dépendance à la france hexagonale
donc nous avons réussi depuis 2014 a
diminué de 2.7 dépendance donc ces
trésors 12 points à redorer ce prix
voilà cette dépendance donc c'est très
important parce que il vient bouleverser
viennent ou bien ce que la part de
gâteau une beaucoup plus grosse et que
la part de gâteau et plus grosse puisque
le nombre de touristes plus important
toujours autant de français mais en
pourcentage
voilà ce qu'ils viennent de la france
hexagonale ou un poids moins important
ce qui est très important pour nous
puisque nous savons que les touristes
qui viennent des états unis dépensent
plus justement que ceux de la france
hexagonale justement l'autre donnée
intéressante que vous avez exposé hier
lors de la présentation de ses chiffres
2010 est c'est que la dépense moyenne de
chaque visiteur sait que 750 euros par
touriste alors c'est beaucoup c'est
assez s'est passé peut faire mieux
peuvent faire mieux on peut toujours
mieux faire et c'est bien pour ça que
derrière yan monplaisir nous le disons
depuis le départ en le tourisme est le
secteur qui doit tirer la croissance
économique et l'emploi
et c'est le cas dans tous les pays de la
caraïbe et aujourd'hui nous faisons du
tourisme un axe prioritaire du
développement de la martinique
on peut dépenser plus les touristes
peuvent dépenser plus et qu'elle sur le
revendre à nos touristes
on va leur vendre beaucoup d'activités
qui sont en train de se créer des
produits innovants
on va leur vendre une bonne gastronomie
on va leur vendre
la tourism le touriste sac à dos qui
allait acheter sa tranche de jambon
lyophilisée dans la supérette du coin
c'est fini ça c'est bien pour ça que
nous nous avons une véritable politique
de montée en gamme de plus en plus que
ce soit au niveau de l'hébergement et
des activités ce que recherchent les
touristes ce sont des choses innovantes
et en particulier les touristes
américains
donc je crois qu'on est dans une bonne
dynamique on peut encore mieux faire
il faut structurer le territoire c'est
bien pour ça que celle ci est américain
vous connaissez le touriste american art
quel point il est exigeant c'est à dire
lorsqu'il vient s'asseoir et qu'il
commande il veut que soient prêts servis
dans les cinq minutes aux 45 min les
exigeants mais les martiniquaises et les
martinique qui travaille je salue tous
les professionnels du tourisme qui
travaillent aujourd'hui dans ce secteur
sont des personnes de plus en plus je
dirais innovantes qualifiés et ont bien
compris je pense que le tourisme est le
secteur qui peut tirer notre croissance
économe 750 euros de dépenses moyennes
par touriste pour qu'on se croit très
bien qu'on n'est pas seulement que
simple sourire ce matin il faudrait
qu'on bien que dépense moyenne
écoutez on peut atteindre 1000 euros on
peut atteindre 1000 euros tout dépend de
ce qu'on propose aux touristes
vous savez quand quelqu'un vient en
vacances et qu'il est bien ils dépensent
et je crois qu'on a tous tout ce qu'il
faut en martinique tout le potentiel
pour pouvoir développer ses activités
terrestres ses activités nautiques
alors ce que j'ai fait quand je suis
arrivé au comité du tourisme
c'est vraiment que chaque secteur soit
bien structurée au comité martiniquais
du tourisme est aujourd'hui les
professionnels ont un interlocuteur par
secteur un interlocuteur pour la
plaisance le nautisme an ou deux un
interlocuteur pour la gastronomie un ou
deux mais aussi pour l'hébergement etc
sony l'organigramme camp pour 2018 il
faudra être plus ambitieux vous dites il
faut développer encore la desserte
aérienne en a parlé d'un avion qui
recherchait des des touristes en
argentine vous comptez aller vers quelle
direction encore nous travaillons
effectivement sur l'amérique latine
parce qu'on sait que qu' il y a du
potentiel en énorme potentiel ce travail
nous le faisons
avec la samain qu'avec l'aéroport nous
travaillons aussi avec le grand port
parce que c'est important et il faut
continuer à aller chercher les nouveaux
marchés c'est ce que nous faisons
d'ailleurs il ya eu il ya quelques jours
le salon roots américain où nous étions
présents en equateur donc nous
continuons effectivement avec l'aca mac
en particulier à développer la desserte
aérienne des bistrots ni la notoriété de
la martinique on va pas revenir sur le
film de lucien jean-baptiste 1 1 on peut
revenir là dessus puisque serait fait
couler pas mal d'encre
eh bien moi j'aimerais bien revenir là
dessus de la mentionne que le diffuse
nous avons trouvé les fonds pour qu'on
voie les excuses et le film promotionnel
sur la martinique
alors nous avons gagné les trophées de
la communication déjà dit ce film à
cannes donc nous en sommes très fiers
cela faisait des années que la
martinique n'avait pas eu un film
promotionnel est un film d'une grande
qualité lucien jean baptiste musique de
victoire oui oui oui j'ai diffusé qu'en
se veut nous allons le diffuser cette
année nous constatons ces postes est
sûrement février déjà corinne oui mais
vous savez que nous avançons puisqu'on
mars nous allons faire déjà une première
campagne sur le web et nous le
diffuserons en principe en septembre en
espérant que le budget évidemment me le
permettra on structurer les filières
également l'expérience digitale
vous avez insisté également sur
l'événementiel durant la basse saison
est-ce qu'on avance un petit peu sur ce
dossier on avance beaucoup donc
l'expérience digitale je veux y revenir
rapidement notre e-réputation est il
faut que nous continuions à la
travailler donc je quand je suis arrivé
beaucoup de reproches sur notre site
internet nous avons travaillé à fond là
dessus j'ai créé une cellule cellule web
qui n'existaient pas donc il ya
aujourd'hui une cellule web au comité
martiniquais du tourisme
trois personnes dédiées j'aurais jamais
embauché de mon salarié nous avons
embauché une jeune j'avais dû renforcer
des fonds vous avez un budget pour cela
on va dire que nous avons restructuré
que nous avons mis l'argent là où il
faut parce qu'il faut qu'ils nous avons
des priorités ses priorités la cgtp a
donc attiré est-ce que vous avez le
budget puisque on se souvient de de vos
regrets annoncé devant la baisse de ce
but chaleur va reposer la même question
quand en novembre dernier est ce que
vous aurez d'argent que vous demandez
vous écoutez là nous le saurons très
vite puisque vous savez que nous votons
les orientations budgétaires
le premier le 2 mars et que le budget
sera voté pas longtemps après donc je
pense que j'ai été entendu que j'ai été
comprise que nous avons été compris
enfin en tout cas nous l'espérons mais
de toute façon pendant ce débat
d'orientation budgétaire nous
affirmerons derrière yan monplaisir le
groupe bat pays en chance nos priorités
d'accord et l'hôtellerie c'est là le
clou dans le pilat du secteur oui les
hôtels aux normes l'hôtellerie reste le
banc le seul et le principal problème du
tourisme en martinique changer le modèle
économique c'est une priorité
nous y travaillons nous avons rencontré
le premier ministre les secrétaires
d'état la ministre de l'outre-mer le
préfet est derrière nous il faut changer
le modèle économique et faire en sorte
que les hôtels et moins de charges parce
que nous sommes pas compétitifs dans
l'environnement dans lequel nous sommes
donc voilà ces essais c'est un combat
que nous que je mène derrière yan
monplaisir merci car il mousse ou
d'avoir une mère ce matin avec nous on
va peut-être vous êtes président du
comité martiniquais du tourisme merci
bonne journée merci
[Musique]